everything we've named so far has been
an alkane we've seen all single bonds
let's see if we can expand our
repertoire a little bit and do some
alkenes so let's see this look at this
first carbon chain right here and I
actually here I drew out all of the
hydrogen's just to remind you that
everything we were doing before with
just the lines it really was
representing something like this and
when you start having the double bonds
and we'll explain it in more detail
later on it actually starts to matter a
little bit more to draw the constituents
because there's actually different ways
that you can arrange it because these
double bonds are you can imagine they're
more rigid you can't rotate around them
as much but you don't think about that
too much right now let's just try to
name these things so like we always do
let's find out try to find the longest
chain of carbons and there's only one
chain of carbons here there's one two
three four five six seven carbons in
that chain so we're going to be dealing
with HEPT
we're going to be dealing with heft that
is seven carbons seven carbons but it's
not going to be an heptane heptane would
mean that we have all single bonds here
we have a double bond so this is going
to be an alkene so this tells us right
here that this we're dealing with an
alkene not an alkane if you have a
double bond
it's an alkene triple bond alkyne we'll
talk about that in future videos so this
is kept-kept and you could we'll put an
N here we'll put it in here but we
haven't specified where the double bond
is and we haven't numbered our carbons
so when you see an alkene like this you
start numbering closest to the double
bond just like as this as if it was a
alkyl group as if it was a side chain of
carbons so this side is closest to the
double bond so let's start numbering
there 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 the double bond is
between 2 & 3 and to specify its
location you start at the lowest of
these numbers so this double bond is at
2 so this is actually HEPT
- 2 n so this tells us that we have a 7
carbon chain that has a double bond
starting the een tells us a double
let me write that down so this double
bond right there that's what the Ian
tells us double double bond between two
carbons
it's an alkene and the double bond
starts if you start at this point the
double bond starts at number two carbon
and then it will go to the number three
carbon now you might be asking but what
if I had more than what if I had more
than one double bond here so let me draw
a quick example of that so let's say I
have something like see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so
this is the same molecule again 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 the way we drew it up here it
would be it would look something like
this but if I add another double bond
what if we had another double bond
sitting right here how would we specify
this well once again we have 7 carbons 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 so we're still going to have
a HEPT
here and it's still going to be an
alkene so we put our in here but we
start numbering it once again closest to
the closest double bond so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
but now we have a double bond starting
at 2 2 3 so it be HEPT
2 and we also have another double bond
starting from 4 and going to 5 so have 2
2 comma 4 n that's what this molecule
right there is now sometimes this is the
I guess proper naming but just so you're
familiar with it if you ever see it
sometimes someone would write a hep to
wean they'll write that as 2 hep diene
and to probably because it's easier to
say 2 heptane and from this you would be
able to draw this thing over here so
it's giving you the same amount of
information and similarly over here they
might say 2 for hep teen but this is the
specific this is the this is the the
correct way to write it lets you know
that 2 and the 4 apply to the in which
you know applies to double bonds let's
do a couple more so over here I have a
double bond and I also have some side
chain so let's see if we can figure out
how to deal with all of these things so
first of all what is our longest chain
of carbons so we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 and we
could go in either direction does
matter seven carbons or seven carbons
and let's start numbering closest to the
double bond double bond actually will
take precedence over any other groups
that are attached to it so let's take
precedence well over any other groups in
this case there will be other groups
that will take precedence in the future
but the double bond takes precedence
over this side chain this methyl group
so let's but it doesn't matter in this
case we would want to start numbering at
this end so it's one two carbon three
carbon four carbon five carbon six
carbon seven carbon so we're dealing
with the HEPT again so it is we're
dealing with a heft and we have a double
bond in the starting from the second
carbon to the third carbon so this thing
right here this double bond from the
second carbon to the third carbon so
it's HEPT two comma three een i'm sorry
not two comma three to e you don't write
both endpoints three if I there's a
three then that would have been a double
another double bond there it's HEPT -
two - e and then we have this methyl
group here which is also sitting on the
second carbon
so this methyl group this methyl group
right there
so on the second carbon so we would say
two methyl two methyl kept to e so it's
a HEPT - een that's all of this part
over here double bonds starting on the -
if we're numbering from the right and
then the methyl group is also attached
to that second carbon let's do let's do
one more of these so we have a cycle
here and once again the root is going to
be the largest chain or the largest ring
here and our main ring is the largest
one and we have one two three four five
six carbons so we are dealing with we
are dealing with hex as our root for
kind of the core of our structure and
it's in a cycle so it's going to be
cyclo X so let me write that so it's
going to be cyclo hex but it has a
double bond in it so it's cyclo hex
cyclohexene
let me do this in a different color so
we have this double bond here and that's
why we know it is an N now you're
probably saying hey Sal how come we
didn't have to number where the ian is
so if you only have one double bond in a
ring it's assumed that one endpoint of
the double bond is your 1 carbon so this
when you write just cyclohexene you know
so if you know cyclohexene it would look
just like this would look just like this
it could just like that you don't have
to specify where it is it's just one of
these are going to be the double bond
now when you have other constituents on
it by definition or I guess the proper
naming mechanism is one of the endpoints
of the double bond will be the 1 carbon
and if any of those endpoints have
something else on it that will
definitely be the 1 carbon so this is
one of the these both are kind of the
candidates for the 1 carbon but this
point right here also have this has this
methyl group so we will start numbering
there 1 and then you want a number in
the direction of the other side of the
double bond 1 2 3 4 5 6 so we have three
methyl groups one on one so these are
the let me circle the methyl group so
that's a methyl group right there that's
a methyl group right there that's just
one carbon alright so we have three
methyl groups so this is going to be
it's going to add set the 1 the 4 and
the 6 so it is 1 comma 4 comma 6 we have
3 methyl groups so it's tri methyl tri
tri methyl cyclo hexane 1 4 6 tri methyl
cyclohexene that's what that is
hopefully you found that useful